so why did you come to the US and where
I came from Serbia which it's part of
Balkans Eastern Europe about eight years
ago you know and a first king I didn't
speak much English I spoke in movie
codes I went to film school and serve
you good school seven people get
accepted each year i but i did watch not
american phones and I spoke in movie
codes you know to get by like I was in a
bar and then a drink I didn't know yet
how to formulate my sentence but I knew
Ben Affleck from Google hunting you know
a picture of the final Agora in the
house and I would say that in the bad
Boston accent and they would get it give
me some beer and that's how we get by a
pull-up Sam Jackson what I need a burger
you know from pulp fiction and it was
funny the first year but in soleus are
trusting myself which is I guess number
one for anyone in the arts and I started
speaking and then I started writing at
my work my uncle got me a job at the
hotel in Santa Monica and I worked at a
front desk for since they got to see the
game here and before I shot this film
that's when I quit
it wasn't like I'm going to Hollywood it
was like really big support of all of
them there you know knowing that this is
coming but I wrote all the scripts at
the front desk and what was that like I
mean you know you mentioned off-camera
that there was times when it was less
busy and you could you know do that
advise anyone who's into screenwriting
that's the job you want because I guess
consistency and discipline the hotel
gives you I mean you have to stand there
for eight hours you're gonna work about
our to have hope they're not watching
this but they know who from my hotel you
two hours at best on a busy day the rest
six hours a guy next to you gambling
online or Facebook so you have all this
free time and you are in front of you
know a monitor so - well download final
draft and start banging away and I draw
about six scripts in you know six years
plus you're watching people probably
come and go
you're noticing people's mannerisms yeah
that's what actually helped me right to
be honest it's somebody approaching and
you have to finish the sentence before
they reach the front desk or the phone
is ringing and you know you either
answer but let me finish this thought
out and right now when I'm home I have
all this time I can now write not nearly
as productively and I think I need mess
around like actually I guys got used to
it so I can go to coffee shops and you
know I need to interrupt it and distract
the in order to focus on writing and you
discover that I didn't know that's how
it becomes so it sounds like that's sort
of inside tip for someone that comes to
LA they want to be in this business find
a day job or my job that's flexible cuz
I've had jobs where there's no way I
could be on computer or anything but
demand they were watching and it sounds
like find a supportive environment where
they cater to artists yeah yeah yeah
that was one of my things it was like
coming here and on a car you went to
film school you should got a job in the
film industry and I thought about it but
then I heard all these horror stories
like all right you're in dopey a six
hours 16 hours a day
I'm gonna be dead and I'm gonna write
like that because you can't you started
directing you're not gonna get hands-on
a great script you know these other guys
already get their hands on the good
scripts and there's no way you know but
I will come to you you have to kind of
come up with your script and if we do
that any time it to write you need to
have a consistency in discipline in
writing and I don't know honestly if
there wasn't for that job how would I or
how long would it take me to pull off
once cut another six this is a strange
question but do you think also too
because you were standing for eight
hours yeah it was different because then
when you come home for me when I've had
computer type jobs the last thing I want
to do is yeah yeah yeah yeah standing
also you you burn more calories anything
look I since I quit the job for like 20
pounds I notice that a lot of people
actually yeah so
you